you bring me down
there's been an awakening
have you felt it
justin you didn't think you can get any
better huh
welcome
to neverland
i brought you into this world
a machine that can think and feel
made a new dinosaur
i have a
word evacuate the island
is our tribe's bravest warrior
what the hell are you doing here
you have to believe that we are better
than we are
but you will never do anything as hard
as staring someone straight in the eye
and telling the
truth i want to tell you a secret
that we'll see you through all the
trials that life can offer
people are always fearful of something
they don't understand it is unacceptable
that they use their power and keep us
voiceless
have courage
and be kind anything you want to do in
your life you can do write poetry have
original ideas
what makes you happy
ever since i met you
my life is
different
my mother used to say something that
drove me nuts
there's a sunrise and a sunset every day
and you can choose to be there for it
you can put yourself in the way of
beauty
you